[Music]
well technology revolutionized schooling
past efforts should leave us weary the
story of EdTech is one of over-promising
and under-delivering to break this cycle
we need to pay more attention to what
educators actually do with education
technology yet major surveys of EdTech
use see more interested in marketing
than in making it work Americans are
asked whether technology makes learning
easier and more fun or whether they
think AI could make a positive impact in
the world of Education teachers get
asked whether using digital learning
tools helps them teach more effectively
and honestly whatever the truth are you
gonna be the Luddite who says no a
better suggestion as teachers how much
time they spent dealing with
uncooperative technology or whether
their districts consider teacher input
when deciding what to buy digital
learning has great promise but achieving
it requires tending to the gritty
reality rather than uncritical
cheerleading have you seen an example of
where school technology actually got in
the way of learning let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI